we begin this half-hour with the lasting
damage of the worst wildfire in
California's history it's been six
months since the camp fire gutted the
town of paradise north of Sacramento the
fire killed 85 people destroyed 19,000
buildings and caused more than 12
billion dollars in damage
Jonathan Vigliotti reports on the
psychological toll the fire is taking on
some of the youngest victims on the
surface children from Paradise
Elementary School appear perfectly fine
you're a strong little girl yeah do you
do this for your mother to keep your mom
strong yes but shortly entire interview
with eight-year-old Ellie warble and her
mom Kylie six months of trauma flooded
through why are you crying Ellie and her
mother's home was among those reduced to
ash by the campfire they've been on the
move ever since recently settling down
in a donated RV you are strong but it's
when you see that's when you see your
mom sad that you feel it the most with
my mom said I get more than 18-thousand
buildings were lost in the fire
including Paradise Elementary at the
temporary school a few towns South
children silently battle their fears so
their parents can worry a little less
all of them have had a turn feeling sad
and needing to talk to somebody
Katie's from ease Ellie's second grade
teacher she says students not only miss
home but their friends too 40% of
students in the district moved away
after the fire she developed a
questionnaire to help get children
talking when was the last time every kid
in this class was happy
I think that's a couple of weeks ago we
had one day that wasn't the only day one
of our teachers coined a new term called
uncertainty trauma because there's so
much unpredictability now school trauma
specialist Scott Lindstrom says it's
also been hard for teachers 529 lost
their homes one of the most difficult
things about this situation
is that on that day there was no safe
place at home no safe place at school no
safe place on the highway
despite the upheaval students are
improving and time is healing that
resilience took center stage at a recent
recital celebrating survival where Ellie
and her classmates sing about a few of
their favorite things in six months
these kids world has changed their
courage is a lesson in strength for us
all
[Music]
for CBS this morning Saturday Jonathan
Vigliotti paradise favorite things I
know look at that group of children they
didn't lose each other no and and it's
really touching like to see what Ella
had the support at Lee wants to give it
to our mom you know how better that's an
incredible gift you think Lee coming up
to Mother's Day yes your hearts really
go out to these kids
yeah they suffer silently it seems like
so many of them and you got you have to
make them talk or find new safe places
for them exactly yeah